Film Courage: Ravi, you were an investment
banker or you did something with finance?
Ravi Patel, Actor: I was!
I was doing my parent’s dreams.
I did finance and I was working in the banking
world.
Film Courage: And what happened?
Ravi: I blew it!
No…I’ll tell you what happened…I got
laid off around 2001 and I’d already used
up my vacation days.
I new…I was just a horrible investment banker.
I hated it.
Film Courage: Why?
Ravi: I knew at that point in my life that
I had to at least try something that I cared
about and that began the journey of me kind
of like spending a your doing a lot of crazy
stuff and eventually after awhile I was in
LA bartending, I was thinking about going
to Law School and I got asked to do an audition
and the next thing you know I was a full time
actor.
It was crazy.
Film Courage: So how do your parents feel
about it now if you don’t mind me asking?
Ravi: My parents love it!
They’re acting now, too!
Success is great.
Every parents excited when it’s working.
But when I first did it they were super scared
because they are naturally conservative.
But now they are literally acting now themselves,
so the tables have turned.
Film Courage: Sure.
Was there a moment where you almost went back
[to the 9-to-5 world]?
I know you said you were laid off?
Ravi: I constantly relapse and say why am
I doing this?
Because acting is a very abusive relationship,
you really have to know what it is.
And I’m also not one of those people (those
rare few) that believe that if you want to
be an actor, that it’s all you need to focus
on.
I actually think to be an actor you need to
have other sources of happiness, other sources
of fulfillment and honestly even other sources
of work and then you can really give yourself
to acting.
Because what makes acting really hard is when
it gets confused with the career because once
you’re relying on acting for money all the
sudden the desperation works its way into
the audition room and some people never figure
out how to do that.
It’s a really difficult career path to also
do it in a way where you’re actually able
to enjoy the acting and not be completely
reliant on the end (whether you succeed or
not) in order to be happy.
Because I work a ton and even then it’s
so often a struggle, lots of ups-and-downs.
So I have to remember what it is and what
it means for me.
And at this point I have a wife, I have a
kid.
I have other sources of fulfillment and I
also have other sources of income because
that is the only way that I can be happy with
acting.